[Music]
5 54 on your monday morning was driving
crazy another viewer question about
hov lanes now this one is not about the
centennial bull area
viewer mack writes hey there are hov on
ramps on the northbound and south on 515
east of the spaghetti bowl but
no hov lanes are there any plans to
change that hey good catch on noticing
those
hov freeway ramps mack and the answer to
your question is
yes there are plans to add hov lanes to
both directions the 95 515 is to spin
east of the spaghetti bowl just don't
expect them to show up anytime soon
now we have mentioned the nevada
department of transportation's plan to
modernize that part of the freeway
i urge you to check out their website
n.dap.com that stands for downtown
access project now they've got an
interactive map there that shows what
the 95 515 looks like
right now here's the view from around
maryland parkway there are three
different proposed
designs all of which include hov lanes
now the first would essentially
lower the freeway from its current
configuration the second
kind of shifts the freeway to the north
and then the third
actually shifts it just a little bit to
the south there's a lot more to the
project
including permanently closing some
streets in and just east of downtown las
vegas in fact
indot has an event scheduled for this
afternoon to talk about that thanks for
writing in mac we got a link to the
n.dap project on our website
8newsnow.com buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com